hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we're going to talk about the
language of pigeons sorry I know that
joke isn't very good but that's all I've
got today I'm going to talk about some
special kinds of languages called
pidgins and creoles you've probably
heard those terms before maybe in the
names of certain languages like pidgin
English or Haitian Creole but please
note there is not just a single pidgin
language or a single creole language
they're actually referring to categories
of languages there are many pigeons and
many Creoles
around the world first what do they have
in common well pidgins and creoles are
new languages that develop when speakers
of different languages come into contact
with each other and have a need to
communicate many pidgins and creoles
have arisen when colonial powers came
into contact with local people as they
spread around the world
so what's the difference between pidgins
and creoles while pigeons are non-native
lingua Franca's well Creoles have native
speakers but let me get into both types
of language first of all pidgin
languages as I just mentioned pidgin
languages have no native speakers
they're languages that arise very
suddenly very quickly when there is a
need for communication in a certain
situation for example for trade or for
labor the pidgin language is a sort of
compromise between two different
languages or between multiple languages
pigeons usually arise when one group of
people is dominant over another group of
people and the less dominant group needs
to learn to communicate with the more
dominant group but without any formal
education in the language of that
dominant group they adopt the sort of
simplified language based on the most
basic vocabulary of that dominant groups
language and based on the most basic
grammar of their own native language
this happens most commonly in situations
of trade slavery or colonial contact and
in a situation like that the dominant
group is usually the colonial power or
the most influential trading partner
imagine this situation an
english-speaking colonial power has a
sugar plantation and they bring over
laborers from various different
countries to that sugar plantation and
those people speak different
but in order to work together they need
to have a common language so they try to
adopt English but since they do this
quickly and they just adopt the basics
the resulting language is a very
simplified language just using the basic
vocabulary of English and a very non
English grammar that is a pidgin
language when pigeons first developed
they are typically restricted in use
meaning that they are only used for a
certain purpose for example on the job
or for trade but some pigeons become
expanded pigeons meaning that they begin
to be used for all facets of life
including social life family life things
like that and they become languages in
their own right even though they are not
native languages they are passed down
from generation to generation as lingua
Franca's amongst people who speak
different native languages now about
Creole languages so pigeons have no
native speakers they arise because of
the need for a lingua franca but if that
language survives and becomes the native
language of the next generation then it
is now a creole language for example
slaves from several different countries
are working closely together on a
plantation but they have no common
language so they develop their pidgin
and it quickly becomes their expanded
pidgin the language they use for all
everyday purposes their children grow up
in that environment with that pidgin
language and it becomes their native
language that is now a creole language
in the days when african slaves were
brought to the Americas they were often
separated from people who spoke the same
native language that was to prevent them
from rebelling or from making plans
together that kind of thing so in those
kinds of situations the pidgin languages
became expanded very quickly and within
one generation sometimes became Creoles
some Creoles are based on English for
example Jamaican Creole some Creoles are
based on French including Haitian Creole
which has 12 million native speakers and
the smaller number of Creole languages
are based on Spanish including chavacano
in Philippines now how different are
these Creole languages from their parent
languages well it depends on the
particular language but let's look at an
example this example is from B Slama
which is an english-based creole spoken
in Vanuatu the first sentence is this is
my house in biz llama
the house belong me or in more standard
English phonology him here house belong
me another example sentence I have
already been to tell in biz llama me bin
long town finish or in standard English
phonology me being long town finish so
look at each word me is like i-beam
that's self-explanatory long is used as
a preposition here instead of an
adjective so long means toward or two
and then we have town
that's like town and finish finish is
used instead of already to show that
something has been accomplished so again
you can see that the words are from
English but they're used and arranged in
a very different way and this is what
makes it a different language than the
parent language
pidgins and creoles are fascinating
because they are proof that languages
are living entities that are constantly
changing and adapting to the needs of
their speakers sometimes two or more
languages can even join forces and take
on a life of their own as a new language
thank you for watching be sure to leave
your comments down below and have a nice
day